what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and we finally have
answers about the contents of that
mysterious top secret information that
stain gave all might plus the final
battle against perfect shigaraki might
be only three days away and on top of
that the ultimate chadlas buff waifu
queen was just introduced i am of course
talking about the strongest american
hero stars and stripes what an
absolutely epic chapter so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the bocano hero
content on this channel and you want to
see more you know what to do just leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot with the
youtube algorithm and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch the
channel but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the chapter starts
off with a flashback to the fall of
tartarus which took place about a month
earlier this was when all for one
orchestrated the dramatic prison break
that set the stage for the current phase
of the story as the giant prison burns
the villains on the inside are ecstatic
at the prospect of getting out and
causing chaos in the outside world once
again some random insane looking
prisoner is screaming about how he's
about to go chase woman in the outside
world and when this guy says chase i
don't think he means that metaphorically
however before this guy can indulge his
sick fantasies stain comes up to him and
straight up ends him with a single
stroke and the fact that he just ended a
guy doesn't even faze stain he just
continues on his mission to find out
what in the world is happening with the
prison man for all the terrible things
he has done you really can't hate stain
he may be known as the hero killer but
he clearly has no qualms about taking
out villains either anyone who doesn't
fit his definition of a just person is
fair game whether they are heroes or
villains and while stain is certainly
not a heroic character he is definitely
consistent when it comes to his moral
code by the way how dark has mha become
we just saw a guy kill another guy and
the story just moves on like it's
nothing anyway because tartarus is a top
secret anti-quirk facility no
information is allowed in or out of the
prison i assume this is referring to the
technology inside the prison it is
completely insulated from the outside
world to prevent potential infiltration
in principle this makes sense you don't
want someone from the outside breaking
into the tartarus system using a quirk
or maybe some sort of high-end
technology so shutting the entire
facility off from the outside world
seems like a no-brainer at the same time
though this means that the heroes and
police cannot coordinate their efforts
on the outside and inside of tartarus as
effectively as they could have otherwise
and this is a weakness that all for one
seems to have exploited in the chaos
that followed the prison break stained
managed to sneak into one of the control
rooms in order to try to find out what
happened how in the world did this super
maximum security facility fall to the
villains most of the prison guards
inside the control room are already dead
at this point but stain does find one
guard who is badly injured but still
alive and conscious this man is likely
the father of shikatsu high student
seiji shishikura who as you will recall
mentioned in the past that his father
works as a guard in tartarus i am
assuming that this is seiji's father
because he is literally the only guard
who has been mentioned in the story up
to this point so having him actually
become relevant to the plot makes sense
stain notices that this injured man is
clutching onto something and this
something seems to be extremely
important to him because he has gone out
of his way to shield it
the guard is clearly on the brink of
death but in his final moments he begs
stain not to give what he was holding to
any of shigaraki's followers he explains
that what he is holding is a recording
device and he decides to entrust its
contents to stain while imploring him to
give it over to someone who is just and
not to hand it over to the villains this
is a pretty heartbreaking scene when you
think about it a tartarus prison guard
who dedicated his life to fighting
villains is now forced to beg a hero
killing villain to do the right thing by
helping out the heroes instead of the
villains this guard has no idea what
stain will ultimately do he doesn't know
whether deep inside stain does have some
sort of moral compass or whether he's
completely evil but the guard has no
other choice he has to put all of his
faith in stain because stain is
literally his only chance of getting
this important intel to the heroes this
guard is not going to make it the other
guards are gone and his only hope is a
hero killer this is both tragic and
poetic at the same time and i really
appreciated this scene this is the kind
of darkness and tragedy that you
definitely wouldn't have seen in the
early arcs of the story and it really
demonstrates the evolution of the mha
manga stain praises the guard's
determination in protecting the
recording device at the cost of his own
life and he assures him that the device
will make it into the hands of someone
just as stain leaves the control room
the guard asks him whether he is a man
or a monster stain replies by saying
that only those who strive for a
completely just world are monsters and
man this line is actually really deep in
the history of humanity so many people
have justified doing terrible things in
the name of some greater good but
normally these people would always make
themselves out to be the heroes and they
would make their victims out to be
villains and monsters who only got
what's coming to them but stain seems to
be different he does terrible things for
what he believes is justice but he has
no illusions about his own role in the
story stain doesn't see himself as a
hero fighting for the greater good he
knows that he has become a monster and
he admits it openly and yet at the same
time stain seems to believe that
monsters like him are necessary in order
to one day create a just society
even if that society is one day
established stain doesn't expect to be
praised for his accomplishments he
expects to be treated like the monster
that he is but he is willing to
sacrifice his own soul for the sake of
his vision of justice as stane escapes
the brutal aftermath of the villain
prison break by throwing himself into
water and then literally swimming to
shore like an absolute mad lad he vows
to give the recorder to the one human he
knows that he can trust the only man
worthy of this information is the man
who started it all almight and this
proves beyond any doubt what i was
saying in my previous mha video stain
pretended not to know that toshinoriagi
in his small might form was really
almight but he clearly knew all along
stain would never have entrusted
toshinori with this information that the
guard had sacrificed his life to protect
if he wasn't 100 sure that the man he
was giving it to was all might himself
after all might receive the device from
staying he handed it over to tsukauchi
and damn tsukauchi looks like he's been
through some stuff like i know
everyone's been through a lot at this
point in the story but tsukauchi really
looks like he's seen some things man on
the bright side though he looks a lot
more badass than he used to now the
reason why the tartarus prison break was
so successful and the reason why such a
maximum security fortress fell to the
villains is because all for one was
using the special properties of his
quirk to communicate telepathically with
himself essentially the all for one
inside the prison was able to
communicate with the all for one inside
shigaraki in order to perfectly
coordinate the prism break from both the
inside and the outside almight says that
one for all also has similar properties
to this particular aspect of all for one
however normally all might could only
communicate with the fragment of his
consciousness inside one for all on a
one-way basis the vestige of all might
inside one for all seems to be able to
get information from the original all
might but the original all mine had
never been able to get any information
back from his vestige that all changed
when almight made contact with an
injured deku back at the hospital when
he touched deku directly almighty
suddenly felt the memories of his
vestige flowing into him and almight
knows that if all for one has a similar
ability or perhaps an even more advanced
version of this ability then all for one
would have no problem communicating with
his vestige even as he was stuck deep
within tartarus while his vestige was
controlling shigaraki on the outside but
it seems that this is not the whole
story because shigaraki now possesses
the quirk radio waves this quirk itself
was apparently used to make this sort of
telepathic communication between the
original all for one and his vestige
more effective because the connection
occurred through radio waves parts of
the conversation between the original
all for one and his vestige were
captured by the tartarus recording
devices and that is the information that
the guard was protecting with his life
after analyzing the recordings the
heroes were able to determine that the
conversation between the original all
for one and his vestige contained the
following words
he will be completed in 38 days he in
this case is of course shigaraki whose
insane awakening procedure was cut short
back in jakku all for one's primary goal
at this point in the story is completing
this procedure as soon as possible
because once the procedure is completed
the new shigaraki will be virtually
unstoppable and since this conversation
was recorded over a month ago it means
that the intel that the heroes got
earlier intel which suggested that
chicago's procedure won't be completed
for at least another two months was
actually false if this tartarus
recording can be trusted then
shigaraki's game changing procedure will
be completed in only 3 days
whoa that is insane we all knew that the
final showdown between perfect chicago
and the heroes would be happening
sometime in the near future and my own
guess is that the final showdown will
take place at the ua but just like the
heroes i also thought that we would have
at least a few more months before that
happens the fact that shigaraki is
supposed to be complete in only three
days time is absolutely unreal and it
means that the final arc of the entire
story could be just a few chapters away
is this already the beginning of the
final showdown will the heroes succeed
in fighting shiguraki within the next
three days or is the completion of his
procedure inevitable from a narrative
perspective it makes sense for shigaraki
to reach his full potential before the
final battle begins because let's face
it that will make the final battle even
more epic but at the same time if
shigaraki does reach that overpowered
state then we have to brace ourselves
for absolute chaos and some serious
casualties among the heroes many will
die including potentially extremely
important characters like all might
isawa and others those minor deaths that
we saw in this chapter could be
foreshadowing other major deaths in the
near future and if all of this wasn't
exciting enough the chapter ends off
with a meeting inside what appears to be
the mha version of the united nations
representatives of various other nations
are apprehensive about sending too many
of their own heroes to fight the
villains in japan because it turns out
that the situation within their own
countries is not that stable either
apparently all for one's tentacles
stretched to many countries not just
japan and if a large number of heroes
from another country end up coming to
japan then the criminals within that
country will likely be emboldened to act
the bottom line is that every country is
primarily concerned with the situation
within their own borders and they don't
want to disturb the equilibrium at home
in the name of helping a foreign nation
like japan basically this un has just as
many issues and divisions as the un in
our own world and in the end it seems
that very little ever gets done through
these official channels that said many
of the top international pro heroes see
all might as a friend and mentor and
they are anxious to go and help him even
as their own countries try to keep them
at home we get a sneak preview of two of
those heroes including an ancient
egypt-themed hero known as salaam which
is the arabic word for peace and there
is another hero named big red dot who
looks like a lion man both of these guys
are running out of patience with their
own governments because they want to go
and help all might now finally we then
meet the strongest hero from the united
states a hero who in the freedom loving
style of the good old usa has already
left for japan without waiting for the
government's permission her name is
stars and stripes she is traveling to
japan by standing on top of a freaking
stealth bomber she is clearly an
absolute mad lass with big juicy
biceps yeah yeah biceps and she's
extremely determined to help all might
whom she calls her master bro what an
absolute queen this woman is we've only
just met her and it's already clear that
she is an absolute badass she looks like
the lost love child of wonder woman and
chuck norris and she also looks like the
female homelander but you know let's
hope she doesn't share homelanders
character traits either way the simping
has already begun online and i'm neither
surprised nor disappointed this woman is
about to absolutely break the internet
and attract an army of tier 3 subs with
miruko lady nagant and now stars and
stripes mha has really spoiled us when
it comes to tough badass waifus and i'm
not complaining let me know what you
guys thought of this crazy chapter is
shigaraki's return really only three
days away and how awesome is stars and
stripes what do you think her quirk is
and how do you think she became so close
to all might finally deku's dad theory
time what if deku's dad works at the mha
version of the un for some reason the
faces of all of those un guys were
noticeably obscured and this made me
wonder why are they hiding their faces
could this be setting up deku's dad
reveal since the story is truly nearing
its final stage it would make sense for
deku's dad to finally appear and if he
really was working for an international
institution like the un it would explain
why he has been away for so long anyway
don't forget to leave your feedback down
in the comments below i always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
boku no hero video and you want to see
more in the future do me a quick favor
and leave a like it only takes a second
but it helps a lot and if you're new to
anime uproar or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
clicking the bell and then selecting
that option that says all if you don't
do that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i wanna give a quick thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algertol hinokamian water the toasted
chi the spike corey mcgowan kaido might
be a gyarados dylan isidor spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody
hebert monkey d quilly and jeremy
cummings finally thank you also to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh the red haired raven
unhell crews rathun deora very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks joy and garcia
ted no ted and fat boy games if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you